خبر اخر ثوره في علوم الحوسبه الكميه
علماء بجامعه العلوم والتكنولوجيا في
الصين يطورون الكمبيوتر الكمي
هو اسرع واقوى الكمبيوترات هو بالفعل
مشاهدينا اسرع من اقوى الكمبيوترات
العمالقه في العالم بنحو 180 مليون ضعف
المهام المتعلقه بالذكاء الاصطناعي
الكمبيوتر الكم الصيني يمكن ان يعمل
باستقرار لفتره اطول ولا يحتاج العمل في
درجات حراره منخفضه للغايه بالتالي يحسن
قوه الحوسبه دون زياده في استهلاك الطاقه
الحاسوب الصيني جيوشان استطاع حل خوارزميه
في اقل من ثانيه بينما يستغرق اسرع حاسوب
عملاق كلاسيكي في العالم خمس سنوات لحلها
لا تدري يا جيو تشانك عندي راويه
[ضحك]
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات